what's up everybody welcome to another
business QA live stream I'm going to be
playing league of legends with J reyez
hopefully going to win and answering
your business questions with my co-host
for the next couple weeks Jennifer price
Jen welcome aboard good morning good
morning I have to elapse you because
this morning adele is joining us you
might hear a few meows in the background
Mike my cat Adela once enjoyed in a
conversation so just FYI see here some
strange meows that's what it is what
what kind of cat is Adela good beyond
he's a tuxedo cat which is like the best
kind of cat ever there's the both social
cat ever I swear she's a dog she like
greasing like I'm home but she plays
fetch and pretty funny I love it so I'm
a little sick today with the sort thing
I can hear that I'm sorry about that
well that's okay I just we're gonna be
my try to pull it all together for today
for processing questions and playing and
talking at the same time we'll see how
it goes but I'm except to help
entrepreneurs usually we do what's in
the cup today but will say what what's
the what's the fantasy today Jensen's
jen's when we're a fantasy yeah my
fantasy is that I am going to give you
quite a that's my fantasy haha i like it
right you're gonna what today I didn't
hear it I'm gonna get a new client
that's that's my fantasy today I'm a a
new client a new business pointless so
that's I'm gonna stay a little fantasy
that I'm gonna get into client today I
love that I love that well we're sending
you good vibes for that too good luck
thank you thank you thank you so much
and of course as usual as you have a
little bite of chocolate here for my
breakfast nice along with my eggs and
salad which is my other favorite
breakfast yeah I've got a whole bunch of
smoothies and a different T this is a
tea for us you should have JR eyes as
nettle tea but this is a throat tea so
where I'm going to try that out and see
how it goes i got in my starbucks mug
yeah but you have a top end quote for us
today jen i do have a quote for us so in
honor of elected day
here in space I found a quote by X
present and I think you're going to like
this one this one's from Teddy Roosevelt
and the quote is believe you can and
you're halfway there I love it yeah I'm
feeling baby yeah little yeah right a
little believe a little fantasy if you
believe in your fantasies you're halfway
there so just believe it at people come
on I love it cool well gee our eyes and
I are queuing up trying to find a match
here and while we do that why don't we
hit up our first question what do we got
alright sounds good so our first
question is from jarabe i'm saying that
right and he says hello sir I want to
start my company can you just give me
some tips should i'd sell found it or
co-founded how many problems will i have
to face and how can i grow a company so
it's kind of a multi-part question there
and wow i love but i love how many
problems will i have to face many many
problems are off so many i think it's
interesting that you're curious about
self sending it or co-founding it I you
know my advice would be to sell found
something unless you already have an
idea with somebody else because
partnerships can be tricky and so I
think it's better to go with your own
gut and what you really want to do first
and before yuko found something unless
again unless you have somebody and you
know if you have a partnership with
already that you already have a passion
with and and how can i grab my company I
mean give outrageous value right that's
what Evan always says so those are my it
doesn't my casa today what about you
Evan cool um the first one why should i
co-founded or self found it and I think
it I think it really depends on how well
you get along with the person you're
going to co-found it there's been
there's been a lot of great companies
that have had co-founders as well a lot
of good companies have just been self
funded our self founded so just depends
on
the relationship you are going into a
business like you're getting married and
so you don't want to just marry somebody
that looks good on paper you need to see
if you were going to work out you have
to go on dates you have to get to know
each other so I think a lot of people
rush into a decision to co-found the
company because their co-founder looks
good on paper right like I'm the
salesperson and you're the technical
person or you're the operations person
so like the skill sets look great on
paper but if you don't share the same
values then you're going to find that
you get into conflict pretty quickly and
it's not going to work out so
co-founding can be a great way to go but
you have to make sure that you share the
same values as your co-founder and i
would suggest working on some small
projects first to make sure you guys get
along and do share those same values
before deciding to go and found this
business together just like you would
date before you get married yeah the
second question was around prop how many
problems is he going to face it was at
the third one uh yeah he was curious
about how many problems we have to face
and how to grow the company right so oh
we got a game hopefully uh you're gonna
face you're gonna face infinite problems
uh right it's it's one problem after
another in the world of entrepreneurship
that that's that's that's the life
you're signing up for um lab for real
man you know entrepreneurship is one of
the hardest things you ever going to do
but if you only look at the problems and
you're you're poaching it for the wrong
way because there's a lot of great
awesome stuff associated with being an
entrepreneur as well but it's the same
thing in life like you could look at
life as one problem after another just
more problems and more problems and more
problems like how many problems have you
faced this week probably a lot some
major some minor so there's going to be
infinite problems every day there'll be
a new problem
but I don't go look at my business and
think I've got to fight more problems
today and tomorrow the next week I look
at the other side of it i look at the
opportunities and look at the growth
that look at the up the ability to help
people so i wouldn't worry so much about
it you'll have to address it and
hopefully the thing that you're doing
you know you love so much that you will
want to overcome those problems but yeah
don't don't let that crush you this is
gonna be so many problems it's just part
of its part of the game it's part of
living you know if you have no problems
than you then you're living your life
too safe and then in terms of how to
grow the business I mean it sounds like
is that the super early stage of just
getting started I would try to look at
finding a first client I would try to
see how can I find my first client what
kind of value can I bring them even if
it's volunteer at the start just
understand how their business works to
really realize how you can start
providing value right like your success
will be determined by how much value you
can bring them we've talked about it a
lot on the stream yeah and and I think a
lot of people start they start with an
idea and then they start with a product
and then it doesn't work out and then
they may be never come back to
entrepreneurship you know you you you
want to create a new mug you have an
idea for this great new mug this great
design for a mug and so you you know by
five thousand mugs with this sick new
design and then you don't sell anything
you've blown a ton of money on it much
better is to try to get to know one
client try to understand their problems
how you can help them solve it for one
person then solve it for another and
then start to get paid for and so I
think he paid more for it get as close
as you can to potential clients I was
just starting up I would try to get as
close as I can to potential clients
start asking questions understand what
the their pain points are
and how it could help them and then just
keep thinking how can I provide value
you know Hayden Hayden my seven-year-old
son um on the weekend said to me hey
daddy I want to be a millionaire and so
I said well you need to provide a lot of
value you got to provide a lot of value
yeah find a product or service that
really helps people that's how you
become a millionaire so yeah I've been
thinking about yeah things like we're
one of my favorite courses um you could
have anything you want in life if you
help other people get what they want in
life yeah I love Zig we did a top ten on
Zig in his 11th him his son or his
grandson wrote to me thinking thanking
us for making it and like spreading the
legacy um so that was pretty cool yeah
yeah I love it are you guys that started
the game yet was like you have maybe uh
we're picking this is champion select so
we're picking who we're gonna play so
Jay rises is back on his experiment of
NASA's top and i have t mode jungle and
we'll see how it goes we're gonna call
oh we're just yet 30 seconds and we
should be in game alright go get them
guys all right on to the next question
and this is from Abdul and he says sir
what about the intimidation that we get
when we're trying to work on something
new I would be doing some new skill when
suddenly I will start getting the faces
of class toppers and other successful
people that have been and my past
failures how to deal with them so I
think what he's trying to say here is
that he is intimidated by all people
that ahead of him that has done really
well and then he looks at his own
sailors he's comparing himself against
people who are more successful and
Abdullah my advice to you is that you
would just
you know flip the script in your head
there instead of being intimidated by
them be inspired by them I know that's
one of the things that really helped
devon was that he modeled the Masters
right he got inspired by other
entrepreneurs and what they did white
and and so look at instead of looking to
add a comparison thing what as an
inspiration thing and you got to do you
you can't compare yourself I think
actually Teddy Roosevelt the guy coated
this morning I think he had another
quote that was similar like I think one
of the worst things you can do is
compare yourself to other people i know
i'm getting the quote a little bit wrong
but anyway the point is is you know you
got it you can't compare yourself you
could be inspired by somebody else so I
think you got to do what you're best at
and instead of being discouraged by
things it's just a matter of looking at
the glass half full instead of half
empty least that's my opinion what about
you Evan was he saying his classmates
are just other people yeah I think we've
seen it he could class topper so I think
what he's saying is people the top of
the class and he sees he saved them and
another successful people and then he
and then he was comparing himself to
them with his own past failures
especially he's trying to new a new
skill she says yeah yeah um yeah i mean
i agree with with everything Jen said to
I think the best comparison that you
should have is is to yourself as to how
you did yesterday and trying to beat
that all the time I think understanding
that a lot of times of people in your
class or the people in your current
environment they're off doing themselves
right like they're off if it's doing
well at school or game you know the jobs
I hear the cat it's funny I know right
he's really thought of Dornan she likes
it um feeling really good feeling the
energy the cat in it out um they're up
doing themselves right and so you need
to figure out like if you if you just
compare yourself to them you're always
going to lose because they're always
going to be a better than
the new we'll all right if you compare
yourself to me you're always going to
lose because I'm always going to be a
better Evan than you will you can't you
can't out Evan Evan I think sometimes
comparisons can be helpful if you're
kind of chasing down a goal or if you
want to model their success you know I
got I I look at Les Brown as a speaker
that I look up to i've talked about a
number of times in the channel you know
young Les Brown I'm a big fan of his
work and so I can learn from that and I
can apply some of the lessons that he
teaches but I don't want to beat him or
I don't want to compare myself to him
and feel bad at myself that I'm not
where he's at because I'm never going to
be a better Les Brown than Les Brown and
so it's modeling the success of
different people and figuring out what
combination can I mash up to be the best
Evan Carmichael and I think that's where
it becomes really important like the
people in your class you don't need to
be better than them you just need to be
better than yourself and it's it's an
easy thing to say sometimes a little
harder the execute if you're in school
and you're not getting the grades and
other people are getting you not maybe
put in the work you don't like the
course but you have to at some point
figure out this is what entrepreneurs do
you know along their path at some point
you figure out I don't want to just live
in the world that other people have
created I want to put my own thing out
there I want to build my own creation I
want to leave my own mark and then
you're not judged by the same criteria
anymore you don't care what what Jimmy
does in class anymore cuz you're playing
a totally different game so I think it's
good to serve as inspiration kind of
like what Jen said but not have it be
crippling for you so that you don't want
to take any action and you feel
worthless because you haven't done
things in the same scale as somebody
else has
the way it's going to come is by you
taking more bets on yourself by you
trying things that are totally different
like stop trying to play that person's
game and start trying to understand how
to play your own that's what I got yeah
love it all right let's go on to the
next question this is from black this
blacks is the pan nine um and he or she
says I'm going to college for RN so I'm
submit your sheets of some dinners but I
don't really love it it's the only thing
I like than anything else and my screwed
if I don't want anything well I ever or
can I be successful and wow I this is a
hard one because if you don't like it
that's hard but I think there's also a
big difference between sometimes some of
the things you're studying to become
something and then the job itself you
know like there's certainly some classes
probably that you don't like but the job
is might be just perfect for you so I
think I think one of the problems I have
always thought when I was I was an
advisor for my sorority in college and I
think people have a vision of what they
want to be but they don't actually
really go and see what it's like in that
particular job itself and they go to
school for years and years and years and
then when they actually realize what it
you know the kind of things they have to
do when they're in that job [ __ ] so what
Lisa them personally right so i would
highly suggest in order to really figure
out than us when you really love you
know you know shadow and nurse for AK
really look at all the different kinds
of nurses that are out there you know
there's probably so many different
niches maybe you would rather work with
you know kids as a pd you know pediatric
nurse vs or maybe you would rather work
with cancer patients or whatever like
look at some of your options and see
it's just something that you would
really love and then the other thing I
would always suggest
is you know if this be so that you won't
really love anything I think you I think
you definitely will love something I
think you could have to explore figure
out what it is and EV it's not a nursing
to be of something else but just follow
your curiosity if you follow your
curiosity I feel like that will always
leave you two to think that you love and
things that you're passionate about and
sometimes you can find things by just
trying to think along the way so yeah
that's my thoughts Evan anything on that
I like it um I think it's I think it's
crazy that that we expect to know what
we want to do you know just coming out
high school and just be able to pick the
right career that we're going to spend
the rest of our lives doing why would
like anything else you just something
just look great on paper and then when
you get in it's just it's not what you
thought and you want to do something
else as you learn more about yourself um
you know like are you a cat or a dog
person and why a tuxedo cat over a
different kind of cat you know comes
right not just by looking it up on you
know an article online and then that's
going to be your decision now you've got
to explore and try and meet different
cats and play with dogs and you know see
what it is and actually you know you get
super excited by where you want to spend
your time so it happens a lot with with
careers worth like a that initial drive
to want to be a nurse like where did it
come from is it you're you know they're
nursing your family you know your
parents want you to do this there may be
that initial drive but once you get into
it it may not be what you want to do and
and I think most people don't have the
courage to switch paths most people once
they start off on something they feel
like they've already sunk so much into
it that they can't switch to something
else and then they just stay on that
path for the rest of their lives and
they end up
up they end up working it like most
people wake up and drive to a job that
they hate for the rest of their lives
and end up just living for the weekends
and that's a pretty sad life so I agree
with Janet that I would be exploring in
and maybe it's just a schooling part
that you're not enjoying and you really
love looking at the people you want it
you still like the idea being a nurse go
shadow a nurse go learn about it see if
it's something that is interesting to
you if you still like that kind of work
if you find that it's not then go find
something else like explore see what
makes you come alive go to career days
shadow other people research you know
you get an inclination one of the one of
the things I've that I feel has really
helped me is when I when I think it's
something when I think of trying
something when I have an idea to do
something if it doesn't make any sense
yet I just try to find a small way to
take some action on it just some kind of
small thing that lets be tested up and I
think it's important because if you end
up stumbling onto things that you never
would have thought would be interesting
you know I look at salsa dancing I
didn't know I was going to be uh I
didn't know was going to love salsa I
didn't know that I was going to be a
salsa dancer that I would eventually run
you know the largest salsa dance school
probably North America growing up I
didn't do salsa dancing I didn't speak
Spanish you know like all of the things
that might have caused me to want to do
this I didn't have that growing up and
so on paper would never made sense but I
walked into a salsa class and I liked it
and I wanted to just keep doing it and
one thing led to another led to another
and you know Here I am and so I think
that is important that you don't always
try to rationalize it and if there's
something that sounds interesting just
try to find some small way to test it
out and see if it is something that you
want to keep doing not putting so much
pressure in yourself that this has to be
the next thing that you're going to do
just like you fit going on on the first
date then you need to you put so much
pressure that this has to be the one
that you're going to marry you're
probably going to screw up that first
date and not give yourself the time to
really hard so yeah I took totally I
thought I always think about this story
about Steve Jobs and how he just took
that pond class right like he just felt
his here ass be there and just explore
something different yeah he dropped out
of school where you know everybody
thought he was crazy and he too he
wanted to drop in on classes that were
just interesting to him and he jumped in
on the typography class so as to learn
about how to often you know words were
written and that became you know the the
core of the Mac why I was so different
or Apple's first product I had beautiful
fonts but he didn't know that he didn't
it's easy to looks he's easy to say it
made sense looking back it's easy for me
to say looking back yeah salsa was it
was a great decision but I didn't know
that going in I think that's what's
really important is you often won't know
it's I agree sometimes you just follow
an inclination you have and just see
where it goes and you never know how it
might affect whatever you're doing later
in life I think sometimes you know you
don't you have no idea i mean i've
searched the exact like it took them a
while to figure out why about it was so
cool for him to take that font class so
um things jump later in life yeah i
think just finding some small way to get
started is super important i think when
we have these ideas we have these big
visions for what we want to do and it's
easy to get lost in the bigness of an
idea it's easy to get you know have the
spare for I don't know how I'm ever
going to do that how is that ever going
to happen you know I'm not I've never
done that at all have the skills you
know whatever whatever you're telling
yourself it's easy to get lost in that
but it's not hard to go to one class
like if you want to be a photographer it
might be it might be really hard to be a
photographer
but to go to what photography class
isn't that hard so just go to the lack
of a clock and see right like to be a to
be a copy right there is a lot of work
yeah this is jen jen does copy for those
you don't know but to go to one writing
class is not a lot of work so so just go
to that class and see what happens maybe
you'll hate copywriting after that maybe
just sounded good on paper but then when
you get into it you like oh I don't want
to do that you know you've gone on first
dates wheres just a total disaster and
you knew right away but it was still a
good idea like the knowing is better
than regret and so just like that
finding that small way to get started
just to try it just to taste have a
little appetizer and see I think is
important probably agree I just want to
give a quick shout out to people on the
chat we've got relaxing sleep station
and say no and even sherry joined us
hope I'm not missing anybody here that's
pretty much at the size of course you
want you and Jay Red Wolf River mom and
we ash and we also a question from
relaxing police station so I thought
I'll just go you thought the next
question alright let's do it alright so
the question is what strategy if any
would Evan use after a collab to
encourage viewers of the original club
video to become engaged subscribers of
their own channel and it goes on to say
we've talked about commenting on every
continent on the original video but is
there anything else other social media
or on their own channel that someone
could be doing to his own channel to
encourage new subscribers and sort of
what you think innovate oh and how he
collab with you what is there anything
else the Daniel could be feeling so it's
kind of a question from licensed
education on behalf of Dana but the
great question i think a lot of people
who have instant interested into it
collapse could learn from this answer i
mean yeah i should copy
you know give them love on social media
and promote on their own channel and
every way you can that's always can
always can be super helpful and I think
to the more collabs you do a craft club
with other people that's helpful so you
can look at people that evan has
collabed with and how about their
channels to you so it becomes kind of
like a little mini building of the tribe
and people you know help support each
other in that way I don't know haven't
you have any more thoughts on that yeah
I think I think absolutely responding to
every comment is is the kind of bare
minimum most people don't do that and
every time I do a collab with somebody I
will go on the channel afterwards and
not just immediately but also go back
consistently for the next week after
about a week things start to die down
but I'll keep going back to see if
there's any new comments youtube doesn't
have a great way to notify if there's
comments on a person's channel so you
just gotta have to go back but I've done
that consistently for some videos I've
taken out an advertising campaign to
help help boost the video I'll promote
it to my own audience and let them know
I have a playlist on my channel that
talks about guest videos that I've done
so I want to promote there I want to
promote their channel I might put in my
newsletter i'll try to be involved in
the rest of the stuff that they maybe
have going on but we're fighting we're
fighting I got a kid and an assist all
right guys Jay Reise cleaning up I love
it um so what else do i do I think my
ultimate goal is I want to be I want I
don't want to see it is just a one-off
collab I think people just get sometimes
too
up in immediate results in just a
one-off thing I look at it as a
long-term relationship and so I'm i'm
also trying to figure out how i can help
them beyond just this one thing so as an
example i did a collab with luis house
who runs a school of greatness podcast i
I'm a fan of his podcast my friend of
his YouTube channel doesn't even like my
youtube channel is bigger than his
youtube channel I have more subscribers
by a huge stretch and he does but I
still put a ton of effort into the
relationship um could he help me with
stuff sure is it my main goal going in
no I just I like helping people who are
on the same path that I am so we did the
interview you know I I promoted on the
channel um I asked him what who are some
like dream candidates that he wished
that he could interview for his channel
and I tried to help him get in touch
with other people I think of somebody
who was recently interviewed on my
channel uh she is daily tweeting out my
book and I'll often retweet that and add
a little happy face or much love or
something there um yeah and I remember
that right like he was one prayer how
many interviews do i do in a month I
don't know a lot and I you know I
remember people but some people are more
memorable than others because of their
vibe and also the effort so I did an
interview with this woman Cloris as an
example she was a great person to
potentially model she asked me if I
would be on her podcast and so my
default answer is always I would love to
how about we do it on my youtube channel
so i can promote you to my audience as
well so i'm trying to be more proactive
in and promotional as well so that hey
why don't we just we can give you some
exposure and you could benefit from you
know having me on your show and almost
everybody says yeah
to that soak Laurie said yes was for her
podcast we did an interview on my
channel and then since she's been
tweeting up my book every day she's been
promoting the video she knew that I'm
doing the book and she offered to making
introductions to me to different other
entrepreneurial kind of podcasts and
friends in her network she hasn't asked
me for anything she might at some point
if she does I'm definitely gonna listen
because you know she's done so much to
help me I wouldn't look at is just like
a trading off though but yeah just
thinking about other ways that you can
you can help if you understand what
they're interested in understand how
they could benefit and just being as
evolved as possible in their mission and
now Xena already is right like Zeno
everybody knows a no in the community
and the live chat and the gratitude
strange is already promoting things you
know on the gratitude journey who
promote the Twitter the twitch
livestream and and if he needed help
with something I would I know who he is
and I would say yes if I could help
right it's an easy yes to say yeah so
xenos are already doing a great job
everything but oh yeah I think yeah I
think say when Evan was talking I
totally forgot about the playlist think
that's a really cool way to get people
to stay on your channel you can even
create a playlist with other videos from
Evan about one word or anyone else who's
helped him like it feeds another
interview on this channel and promoted
it on one word you create a whole
playlist on that so that way if people
come across your video you might say in
your channel cuz they're watching with
other videos even if they're not yours
that's okay you can still create a
playlist and then they might see much
more of your other videos and they learn
of course tactical thing is a obviously
when you tab the videos you can tag Evan
in there and one word in there and all
those things I'm sure you've already on
that they know but you know for anyone
who's listening that's a great way to
help but come up in the search box
people
searching for information about a
bananas book yeah okay so how's the game
going game is going well good at least
you're not losing game is going well
somebody just wrote Smith wrote back
where we're tie we're 16 and 16 16 kills
16 deaths I have one kill and seven
assists so I'm doing a lot of work here
so far but you gotta do gotta do better
this game actually favors us because the
champion that both Jay rise and I are
playing the longer the game gets the
more powerful we become so this is good
oh if we're tied where we are now then
it's only gonna be better we're
expecting early really lost to then make
it up later on but we're not losing that
much early so this is what's going well
we'll see cool and say no it's put
enough as an asset thank you in the chat
box to you Evan for answer my question
and complimenting him ulcers alright so
next question is from Joe and Joe asked
evan i'm an entrepreneur but it's hard
to really follow my dreams with school
some days I'll be in school for over 12
hours and it drains me out and I really
hate it I don't want to drop out because
I want my diploma for a good starting
job just in case on business sales and I
have to make my mom proud I'd bite ? um
that's a tough one man could you know
you're hating school you're spending all
this money on school and you're not
going to use it that's tough but at the
same time I'm not going to be that
person to this dress because that's
between you and your mom right but I
feel like if there's a way you can
utilize school to help you with your
business that's probably the best of
both worlds that it'll probably motivate
you to do better in school there's a way
to do that you know utilize school to
help you with the things that you're
super passionate about and maybe take
classes
things that won't but you're just
interested in collector we're talking
about earlier with your curiosity
sometimes you don't know why you're
interested in that you don't know how
can separate business then actually take
it you realize how you might be able to
utilize that passion with what you're
already doing in your business but
obviously you're not telling us what
your business is but I think there's
probably no matter what it is probably
thinks in the school to your taken a
copy of it that's why 57 yeah i like i
love it as an interesting I like the
approach um I have the same kind of
concerns Jen does and that you know I
don't want to I've I but there's a
love-hate relationship with school I
think it's important first in some
respects but like the biggest thing I
learned from school is Oh under attack
biggest thing I learned from school was
just the connections the the people much
more than the skills that I learned I
think if you're going to be an
entrepreneur I don't think this deals
are going to be super amazing that
you're going to learn in school but if
you're trying to get a job then it is
going to be pretty important you're
making life hard on yourself if you
don't have the schooling now at some
point you need to figure out are you
going to live down your mom's life or
you can live your life and what point is
that gonna come up right you know I
again at the beginning your you want to
make your parents proud and you want to
do the thing that they want you to do
but at some point you're going to have
to make the decision that like hey I'm
now gonna live my life on my own whether
that's now or whether that's after you
graduate or you know whatever point in
your life you're gonna have to figure
that out a couple of ideas come to mind
if you're really not liking it want to
play off of jen's idea i would say when
i was in university I used my school
resources to help my business and so as
an example I wouldn't
only just take classes that I thought
might help me but i also created my own
class with my professor where is
basically there's a custom create a
class if you can get to know one of the
professors and something that you wanted
to do for your business you can turn
that into your own self-study course
with them as your kind of mentor and
guide so no exam 2 which was awesome I
enjoyed that so that was something that
really helped me i would also always use
my business so i was one less class to
take basically right I would use my
business as a way to be involved in the
different projects so like if we had a
marketing assignment in the class I
would use it I would use my company as
the example right like hey create a
marketing plan for XYZ company okay well
how about I do my own company right so I
would do that much distantly um I always
found out that helped me through whoa
I'm under attack and how that helped me
through a lot so super appreciative of
that oh I gotta kill but I'm being
chased I got a double kill all right
team is doing well so no no that can
help as well I was able to go in like we
also my company's sold to universities
and so I could go in and do my you know
research project we're really I was like
getting super important information for
my company so looking at is there
anybody that you can sell to within
university and then use your coursework
because I would go in and say hey I'm
collecting data for my marketing class
you know can I come and interview you
and they would say yes because it's not
a sales call it's a university research
project which they're much more likely
to say yes to so that was all super
valuable for me and helped me get
through the pain and frustration and you
know maybe
anger of being in some of those classes
the other approach that I would also
recommend is I would look at guys like
Michael Dell and one thing I come really
inspiring but him was he he wanted to do
his own company he wanted to start dell
computers but his parents wanted him to
be a doctor he was in med school
studying to be a doctor um what under
attack oh I died very sad first death oh
I'm very sad it's okay it's okay so
tears um he went to be a doctor and his
parent wanted to be a doctor and he said
you know what give me one summer to try
give me one summer to try my computer
thing and he was just basically building
his own computers from his dorm room and
if you know I don't get fine take a
summer and do it and he ended up making
a successful and he never went back to
school and ultimately made his parents
proud like if your mom wants you to be
successful just success in her eyes as
go get a safe steady job she doesn't
want to see you suffering on the street
so you know it's coming from a place of
love so that could be another option to
whether you take a year off whether you
take a summer off and and work towards
that and you know that that's your goal
you know like okay I only have to get
through until the summer and then I'm
going to do this that can help so both
of those options are way to kind of stay
in school not totally give up on it yet
whether you do it over the summer
whether you try to sign your own courses
or whether you use your existing courses
to help your current business and if it
ends up still being just absolute
torture for you you may want to start
looking at at what point are you gonna
say hey you know what I've given this my
best shot I want to do my own thing
cool i love it i love you using your
experience there FFF awesome obviously
can relate we have another new person in
the chat and the name is choked on my
duck that's a hilarious name i have to
say i'm a university organ junko and i'm
not sure about that name at all other
than maybe we're just so fierce that you
know you're choking on it anyway um this
person has a question though he's 17
years old still in school in 11th grade
and as curious about how to start
getting passive income start a business
or r smith and then like you know a
believe teen their hashtag i love it so
obviously cares about passive income and
i mean obvious there's tons of different
ways to get past with income i think
have income though is tough because i
think it's better if you don't have some
kind of you know service or no that's
based on for example if you're doing an
online course a lot people who are most
successful doing on my courses done you
know service in that area for a while
visit consulting and they know enough
about it to be able to create a course
for that um you know obviously there's
things like you know being an affiliate
affiliate marketing and again like if
you're for example how to youtube
channel you're obviously giving value in
sub specific area and yes the jealous
meowing here in the background again
this is jerry made a comment in chat box
there anyway um so yeah those are my
size I mean obviously terms of different
kinds of passive income so don't know
which your which of us are Evan on that
if you have any I think people searching
for passive income are for the most part
deluding themselves
I think if you want to be able to be
successful I think if you want to be a
successful entrepreneur and you want to
make a lot of money it's going to come
from doing things that provide value to
your audience and not just like don't
look for an easy up it's like I want to
like people who just look for the
shortcut often never get to where they
want to go or even close they're just
constant going in circles and circles
and circles looking for the next
shortcut and they never do anything of
real substance if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur stop looking
for passive income and start looking at
something that you can enjoy doing like
start looking at work that you would
enjoy actually working on what is that
that's what you want that's what you
want to go for well it yes agreed so I
think too many people get that wrong
yeah I think people who are most
successful passive income or they're
doing other things first so they're
passionate about that are related to the
passive income I was trying to say like
I think you have to really like do
something else besides just get passive
income or you like you said you're not
really gonna get anywhere well most
people weren't stood in passive income
they don't want to they don't want to
work for what they're doing weird like
that you need to find joy in the work
and ask me something about the work that
you love doing that's that's the key so
what do you enjoy about the work i just
got a triple kill you even know what I
was doing but I'm happy with it yeah
looks like we're gonna win Lulu victory
good game all right love it um and just
my gut says something about not English
is in this first language but I think I
think they understand what you're asking
and I think evidence answer pretty
pretty so safe there yeah start looking
at doing something that you love that
can add guy that can that can make money
so you want to make money start start
helping people what can you do that you
love that helps people that's it and
enjoy spending the work like
enjoy the time you're going to spend
your time on something do it in the
service of others in some method Oh team
I got an S Plus on t-mo I ended up going
nine kills one death and 10 assists
jerez had seven kills no deaths and yeah
we got a victory I'm pretty pumped
pretty fun sup guys that's awesome that
people kill probably help whatever that
was the way of the three people how to
kill it yeah yeah no it's good yeah yeah
um so now i'm reading the chat it comes
from from a poor family my goal is to be
rich yeah don't have a goal just to be
rich it's not a great goal because
people have a goal to be rich often
never get there usually don't get there
because here's the problem right you say
like I want to be out here I want to
accomplish all of this stuff out here
and I'm here and I'm willing to do
whatever it takes to get to that spot
and I'm going to suffer through all of
this crap to get to this point where
your desire to be rich isn't going to be
enough to get you through the craft and
you're going to quit when you get into
any business you say okay let's get in
the real estate it real estates amazing
realist it's a great way to make money
great you're getting to really sit you
realize you don't like it it's not for
you but you're going to keep doing it
and then struggling and suffering and
suffering and you never get good at it
because you don't love it and then you
never get rich you have to enjoy the
process if you're telling yourself
you're going to do anything to get there
but you don't enjoy the process you're
never going to get there that's the
problem you're going to quit cuz it's
going to get too hard it's going to get
too hard because the people who you're
competing against love what they're
doing and they're always going to beat
you so you're going to be average at
best
so you've got to find the thing that
makes you come alive that you love that
you can crush the competition at that
helps other people then it's van to
their lives you know there may be other
people that have different views and if
you believe in them then go and try go
and try for yourself don't don't take it
as absolute truth just because I'm
saying it but if you go out and try to
create multiple streams of passive
income understand that you know there's
almost no such thing as passive income
there's still work that has to be done
unless you're buying you know an index
fund like it pays out dividends okay
there's no work there you don't the
manage the fund anymore but almost
everything else you still have to do
some degree of work and if you don't
enjoy the work you're never going to get
good at the work and if you never get
good at the work and they're going to
provide enough value if you don't
problem value you're not going to make
enough money so find the thing that you
love doing that can really help other
people's lives and go all in on that for
all the people who say go and create
multiple streams of income I think that
works great when you're investing but I
think it's a terrible strategy in
business and if you look at the
wealthiest people in the world you want
to be rich go look at the richest people
in the world and see how much of what
they did to build their wealth was by
creating multiple streams of income
Andrew Carnegie who's the richest man in
the world said put all your eggs in one
basket and then watch that basket so
good luck huh those are my thoughts I've
in there get to go in a little rant
multiple streams of income rant I love
it so we won good one thank you guys to
the game Jen so the tradition out here
at the end that three she started was
wrapping everything up the final thought
after listening to all of this what's
the final message of the day from
Jennifer price yeah I think the final
message is to just explore I feel like a
lot of the questions that was a really
good answer um you know explore follow
your curiosity you know try things and
see if you like it and go from there in
business and I totally think it would
help no matter what you're doing that's
my summary my little extra thought of
the day I love it I love it cool well
great start Jen I'm looking forward to
the next couple weeks together thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
have an amazing day go and and crush
your business today happy tuesday we
believe in you we hope we continue to
believe in fantasize and rise yeah yeah
much love we'll see you soon think that
I